I'm J I'm
John banking card and marriage
registration married yeah
guess they didn't bring up that we'd be
pairing to the last interview it's an
old KGB tactic can you draw us attention
as a
couple
very
romantic what is it that you two
do we software Engineers administer
single dose no
casualties what you think if the company
had matched you you'd be compatible you
act you're sitting underneath a shelter
I made I made this fire I got shelter
food fire water now
maybe work life romance they're all part
of the same project you said you love
me yeah you did
too we're about to
die so you didn't mean it no I
do that's
cool
don't do
that
[Music]
sorry it's just a job it is not life and
death
see you feel
[Music]
better